このようなことが起こらないことを願っていますが、麦わらの一味の誰かが死ぬ可能性はあるのでしょうか？
Hi, I asked the best one piece YouTube in
Japan the 17 most burning questions around
the series.
2 weeks ago, I decided to share one of the
best one piece theories I have ever come across.
This theory by Yuderon talked about the true
nature of laugh tale, the one piece as well
as the ancient kingdom.
And after translating the video, condensing
it and adding my own thoughts and findings
on top, I published the video, gave it a very
daring title and went to bed with a feeling
that this might be interesting to those who
watched it.
What I woke up to the next morning, was basically
chaos.
I was drowned in mentions and messages and
fighting my way to my channel page, I saw
that the video had gone viral.
As of now said video stands at a staggering
two and a half million views.
And I'm honestly still trying to process what
happened.
Of course the real star here was Yuderon,
who's hard work and dedication to the story
made this all possible.
And since many of you guys haven't had any
interactions with the Japanese anime and manga
community yet, I decided to ask Yuderon whether
he would be willing to do a little Q&A, so
you could get to know him a bit better.
So I gathered all your questions I received
on YouTube and Twitter and to not overwhelm
the poor man, condensed it into 17 ultimate
questions that I think cover the most ground
for what everyone wanted to know.
Yuderon does weekly chapter previews, reviews
and theories on his channel and recently has
successfully predicted that Yamato would be
a righteous and female character.
That Onigashima would be moved.
That Yamato's mythical dog would play a role
in the story as well as the exact chapter
in which Jinbe officially joined with Luffy
and Co.
Oh, and since we made this Q&A in text-form
on Twitter, I asked one of my Japanese friends
to read Yuderon's replies, so it's a bit more
engaging.
Thanks Shota!
Here we go.
1.
好きなキャラクターはいますか？その理由は？
I wouldn't have guessed that, but I definitely
know where he's coming from.
Next.
2.
ONE PIECEに興味を持ったきっかけは何ですか？
Nice.
Next.
3.
どのようにしてあなたのワンピース論を作っていますか？
Okay wow, this was a lot to digest.
Yuderon has found 3 things Oda does regularly
that he bases his theories on.
The mirrored structure of the story, that
we kind of know about in the west as well,
the wordplays and symbolism, which I'm personally
a big fan of.
No wonder his theories are awesome.
Next.
4.
日本では誰もが「ワンピース」を知っていると思われがちですが、日本における「ワンピース」の一般的なイメージはどのようなものなのでしょうか。なぜこんなに人気があるのでしょうか？
A lot of people asked this question, but I
think living here, I definitely agree with
Yuderon, that people love One Piece and other
stories here for the same reasons as we do.
Storytelling unites us all.
Next.
5.
海外ではそれぞれのワンピース論や…日本では、ワンピースの話になるとどのような話題でしょうか？
Now I could blame this on my bad translation
of the question, but I'm gonna be a dick and
blame it on the question.
See, there is no beef between Zoro and Sanji
in Japan.
Next.
6.
あなたのワンピース論には日本語を知っているからこそ理解できるニュアンスがたくさん含まれます…翻訳で失われると感じるものは他にもありますか？
I guess there wasn't really anything else
he could think of in terms of language barrier.
From my personal experience though, I think
there are many references and other puns with
names and so on, that make a lot more sense
as a Japanese person.
Though I guess this is more a cultural and
less a language problem.
Next.
7.
次はだれに麦わら帽子がわたるのかというのも是非聞いておきたいです
Okay this one was clearly my fuck up.
I wanted to ask who he thinks the next straw
hat will be, but I butchered the translation.
Luckily enough he gave me his answer later
on.
He also basis this on the wordplays with the
devil fruits, you might have come across before.
Gomugomu, hitohito, hanahana, yomiyomi, leaving
2 and 9.
By the way, when you add up these numbers:
56 + 110 + 87 + 43 + 29 you get 325, or san
ni go.
So for possible devil fruits, Yuderon gave
me the Nikyunikyu fruit, which is Kumas.
The Fuku fuku fruit, which is Kinemons, the
jikijiki fruit, which is kids or the jukujuku
fruit, which is SHinobus.
Since Yamato would be inu, so 1 - 2, he thinks
she doesn't fit.
He told me that he isn't really sure how it's
gonna play out, but he could imagine Franky
inheriting Kumas fruit and Vivi joining as
the 10th member, as that would connect past
and present again.
First vivi wanted to join the crew anyways
and in one of the one piece magazines, the
initial concept for the 10th member was titled
as Bolero, which would fit Vivi's image as
a dancer.
I don't like that this makes sense, because
I still want Yamato to join.
SO, next!
8.
誰もが憧れる尾田先生にお会いできるとしたら何を聞きたいですか？
That's a very humble answer.
I would probably ask Oda something important,
like why Sanji is so much stronger than Zoro.
Next.
9.
海外のワンピース・コミュニティについて、どのようにお考えですか？
I'll leave that one to you guys.
Let Yuderon and me know in the comments what
you think.
Next!
10.
尾田先生の大変な仕事ぶりは誰もが知っています。あなたの説では、マンガ家としての彼はほとんど人間離れしているように見えます。しかし、日本全体での一般的な尾田先生のイメージや仕事ぶりはどうなのでしょうか？
Man this one really shocked me.
I think we should all stop complaining about
any breaks that Oda takes.
The poor man
deserves some rest.
Next.
12.
語呂合わせというと、欧米のファンは小田先生の使う語呂合わせには懐疑的な人が多いですね。ユデロンさんの作品にはそのような語呂合わせの話が多く見られます。これは尾田さんが本当にわざとやっているのではないかと思うのですが、いかがですか？
This was so interesting to
me to hear.
I originally was REALLY no fan of these wordplay
things, but I've completely changed my mind.
Let#s wait for chapter 1031 I guess and see
what happens.
Next!
13.
和の国は今、クライマックスを迎えています。しかし、和の国の次はどのような冒険になるのとお考えでしょうか？
I really can't tell you how ready I am for
ELbaf and finding out what happened at
the reverie!
Next!
14.
月が『ワンピース』の象徴としていかに重要であるかは、広く知られています。エネルは月に行ったこともあります。実際の月は物語の中で重要な役割を果たすと思いますか？
Never thought of this, but it makes so much
sense my head hurts.
That would truly be an ancient weapon.
Next!
15.
時折、「ワンピースはもうすぐ終わる」と言われていますが、まだまだ終わりには程遠い感じがします。ユデロンさんは、ワンピースの最終章が見られるのはいつになると思いますか？
I kind of feel the same way if I'm being honest.
I want the story to continue on forever, but
also want to see how it ends.
Ahh, the dilemma.
Next.
16.
古代兵器についてはどうお考えですか？彼らの目的は何ですか？
I
like that idea.
I've also thought about it along the lines
that the ancient weapons really depend on
who uses them and how.
They might truly be just really great pieces
of technology or powers that pose a threat
to the world government.
Next.
17.
日本語を話せない多くの人々が、あなたのビデオを見たいと思っています。動画を英語に翻訳する予定はありますか？
There you have it guys, make sure to subscribe
to Yuderon, his channel is linked in the description.
Next.
Here's a bonus for sticking around till
the end.
Here's one more video
for you!